- [Narrator] Located in Romania
around 400 feet below the town's surface
is the Salina Turda,
an underground theme park
inside one of the oldest
salt mines in the world.
(upbeat music)
Salina Turda is believed to
be nearly 2,000 years old.
During its time as a salt mine,
it is estimated that over
three billion tons of salt
was excavated from the walls
before mining stopped in 1932.
This underground hub has
had various uses in the past
from a cheese storage center
to a World War II bomb shelter
but its current usage is
perhaps its most unique.
In the early 1990s Salina Turda
was carefully converted
into a subterranean theme park and museum.
This active park includes
a 180-seat amphitheater,
an underground lake with
paddle and row boats,
mini golf course,
ping pong tables and of
course, a Ferris Wheel.
Over 2 million people have
visited since its opening.
The dizzying effect of the place
will leave you feeling
like you've left reality
in this subterranean wonderland.